as afghanistan collapses and no one in
our federal government wants to take any
responsibility for it our woke chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff has finally
stepped up to explain what happened the
problem you see with the withdrawal and
subsequent collapse of afghanistan is
that
no one knew it would happen
the time frame of a rapid collapse
that was widely estimated and ranged
from weeks to months and even years
following our departure
there was nothing
that i or anyone else saw
that indicated a collapse
of this army and this government in 11
days
ignorance is not an excuse sir
excuse me i would ask you to use my
preferred pronoun son oh god sorry sir
it's ma'am okay frankly ignorance may be
the best excuse this administration has
of all the press conferences that we
have seen over the past few days from
the chairman of the joint chiefs to the
defense secretary to the president
himself the sad fact is that the most
coherent of them all
was probably from the taliban i'm
michael knowles this the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from bobby who says
i like how libs always say they own it
or take responsibility and then refuse
any type of punishment or negative
fallout yes this was i'm glad you picked
up on that this was the defining feature
of joe biden's speech on afghanistan he
said i take responsibility the buck
stops here and it was all trump's fault
and it was the afghan army's fault and
it was the
state department's fault and it was
everyone's fault but mine but i take
responsibility it's a brilliant little
trick
i'm sure it helps them rest easy at
night and if you want to rest easy i
would recommend you check out my pillow
there's a lot of bad terrible woke awful
companies out there aren't there
there's a great patriotic company too a
great conservative patriotic company
that stands by you and your values that
would be my pillow but frankly i would
shop from my pillow even if they were
communists perhaps even if they were run
by the taliban because
my pillow makes great products my pillow
created the new giza dream bed sheets
they look and feel great means an even
better night's sleep
my pillow found the world's best cotton
called giza it's ultra soft and
breathable but extremely durable my
pillow sheets come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee and a 10-year
warranty the first night you sleep on
the giza sheets you will never want to
sleep on anything else giza dream sheets
come in a variety of sizes and colors
they're fabulous slept on them last
night they felt great they always feel
great right now sale of the year you get
them for
49.99 go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listeners square use promo code
daily wire there you will find not only
this wonderful offer but offers on my
pillow mattress topper my pillow
telesets and so much more call
1-800-651-1148
use promo code dailywire or go to
mypillow.com make sure you use promo
code daily wire
so
the woke general mark milley chairman of
the joint chiefs says
hey don't blame me i had no idea that
that could happen
as if that excuses it it's like well
yeah you should know that that could
happen pal that's your job in fact that
might be the single most important
aspect of your job
right now is knowing what is going to
happen during this
major american military withdrawal from
a place that we've been in for 20 years
you should you should maybe know the
options of what could happen the defense
secretary was not
was not any better frankly he was worse
defense secretary lloyd austin was asked
at a press conference with general
milley hey
what about all the americans that are
over can you guarantee that the
americans will get out before the
american
military leaves and he says
nope
and i would draw a distinction bar
between extracting
uh
someone in an in extremist condition or
a circumstance versus going out and
collecting up large numbers of uh of
american citizens do you have the
capability to go out and collect
americans
we don't have the capability to go out
and collect up large numbers of
people
oh my goodness gracious this guy makes
millie look competent
and millie
is useless you'll remember that millie
was testifying before legislators on
capitol hill and he was asked about the
the imposition of critical race theory
materials in the reading lists for the
troops and he defended it he defended it
very
very strongly he said we we need i want
to understand
marx and marxism and not just understand
it by the way but actually push
materials that were promoting it i want
to understand white rage
maybe
maybe
if the taliban had been motivated by
white rage maybe then
millie's plans would have worked out
beautifully but unfortunately white rage
had nothing to do with it because white
rage is not a threat to this country
certainly not a threat to our withdrawal
from afghanistan so much as the taliban
and islamism which we can't talk about
and by the way
millie blew it
lloyd austin blew it
joe biden
did marginally better and the reason he
did marginally better is he was finally
asked to take questions from the press
he was doing an actual press conference
you remember he gave that speech on
afghanistan and just ran out of the room
and didn't want to take any questions
from the press about it after so he's
finally taken some questions
but the only thing he wanted to talk
about was
the coronavirus and the vaccines and
republican governors
unfortunately
as you've seen throughout this pandemic
some politicians are trying to turn
public safety measures that is children
wearing masks in school and the
political disputes
for their own political gain
some are even trying to take power away
from local educators by banning mass in
school
they're setting a dangerous tone
for example
last week at a school board meeting in
tennessee
protesters threatened doctors and nurses
who were testifying making the case for
masking children in schools
intimidation and the threats we're
seeing across the country are wrong
they're unacceptable
and i've said before
this isn't about politics it's about
keeping our children safe
who
cares about
coronavirus
nobody nobody cares it's just not that
big a deal
the country that we've been occupying
for 20 years just collapsed with
thousands of americans behind enemy
lines in an event that we were told
could not happen it was not going to
happen there you have no plan to get
them out and you're talking about a
cough you're talking about a freaking
cough
nobody cares buddy
oh my goodness you know who doesn't care
about coronavirus
the taliban you'll know do you know who
doesn't care about virus the afghan
people do you know who doesn't care
about coronavirus the american soldiers
and civilians who are in afghanistan you
know why because it just doesn't matter
that much
the only masks right now in afghanistan
are the the taliban fighters and the
burqas that they're putting on all the
ladies that's what that's those are the
masks and it's not to keep out the virus
or slow the spread
why why oh why is joe biden talking
about this stupid cough that doesn't
matter
relative to other events in the world
it's not an accident
it's not a mistake it's not a flub or a
gaff it's very intentional
the reason and i've seen the polling on
this the reason is that joe biden's
approval rating and and favorability
numbers are tanking they're collapsing
just about as fast as the nation of
afghanistan the former nation of
afghanistan
over his mishandling of the withdrawal
they're collapsing over his handling of
immigration they're collapsing over his
handling of so many aspects of our
national policy the only area where joe
biden is posting consistently positive
numbers is coronavirus because he and
the public health bureaucracy are
keeping everybody scared for 50 the
longest 15 days in human history
they're just gonna they're just gonna
try to ring out this fear-mongering for
as long as they possibly can so it is to
joe biden's political advantage only
ever to talk about coronavirus and never
to talk about the economy immigration
least of all
afghanistan
he went on for something like 15 minutes
about the stupid virus and the governors
that are doing a much much better job
handling the virus than he is
and then
at the end of that
without really addressing the issue the
big issue in the room
he just left
we just need to finish the job
with science with facts and with
confidence
and together
as united states of america we'll get
this done
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops thank you
the nearest we came to an actual
confrontation of this problem that's
going on in afghanistan that he told us
wasn't going to happen was at the very
end he's like yeah these governors are
terrible and covet it's the scariest
thing ever and you all need to be really
afraid of it forever and okay
god bless our troops bye see ya peace
i'm not a crook see you bye
pretty pathetic stuff
so we've seen now three press
conferences
four if you include
joe biden's address about afghanistan
that didn't take any questions from the
press so you've got three major ones
from top officials in the united states
responsible for what's going on in
afghanistan
there was an actual fourth press
conference related to this issue
that one was on sort of the other side
of the
of the battle that one was put out by
the taliban
and
it kills me to say it
it was by far the most coherent and
serious press conference of any of them
the taliban put on a much better show
the taliban treated the the press with a
far greater respect and the taliban
were much more verbose
and much more uh willing to discuss what
happened than anybody on the american
side
which should be no surprise by the way
because the taliban
won
they won
i don't think they won because the
american troops weren't fighting hard
enough i don't think they won because
they actually even won any proper
battles in in recent years
they won because the political
leadership
just bungled they just they bungled
the mission they bungled the definition
of what was going on there they bungled
the government building obviously the
government collapsed in 11 days they
they bungled building up the afghan
military they bungled the withdrawal
they bungled every
aspect of it
and so the taliban came in
now they tried to assuage fears in the
west
fears about terrorism
fears about drug smuggling and human
smuggling and they also took a few shots
at the west
that landed that actually cut to the
heart of some of the hypocrisies
in the western regimes
taliban leader sitting there in the
presidential palace
holding the press conference first is
asked are you going to allow al qaeda to
fester how about your
relationship with al-qaeda
do you still have a connection with them
we want to reassure that afghanistan
will not be used against anybody
wants to take advantage of our soil our
country
we will not be allowed they will not be
allowed
secondly the government is being formed
yeah and very soon i promise that you
will have a government and a rule of law
okay so on its face there's no reason to
believe the taliban these guys generally
don't deal in good faith and they hate
america
as they took kabul they were chanting
death to america do you remember there
was that reporter that american reporter
who said you know they're chanting death
to america but they seem friendly and so
there's no reason necessarily to believe
them except for this
the last time that the taliban
permitted
terrorists to plan an attack on their
soil against the united states
we killed tens of thousands of them and
drove them from power for 20 years
so yes we didn't totally vanquish the
organization yes they did come back into
power but that is a pretty strong slap
on the wrist
when when you have tens of thousands of
your brothers in arms killed and then
you are kicked out of power for two
decades
that actually might
change their behavior a little bit
and if not i imagine the united states
will just go back in and start mowing
them down again
again no reason to take the taliban at
their word whatsoever but
there is unless they're complete maniacs
they might tone it down a little bit
with the with the state sponsorship of
terror
then the next question once you deal
with the terror problem the next
question is drugs
the main crop in afghanistan is opium
that is their export that's what they
make a lot of drug trafficking goes on
in afghanistan and from afghanistan and
the taliban probably the only the only
positive thing you can say about them
is that when they came into power they
stopped the opium they cut it out they
stopped the production of opium
now they are saying they will stop it
again
giving the assurance to afghanistan that
there will be no production of
drugs in afghanistan
during the government the past
government
the uh of hume cultivation was on high
drug production was happening but we
will be against that
there will be no drug production
no drug smuggling
this was making me very very sad
that our youth our young
will not be a country of cultivation of
opium anymore
so i i mentioned this bit one it's it's
not surprising taliban this is not them
lying they actually are against the
production of opium in the country i
mention it though just to
show how
serious they're presenting themselves in
this press conference now what they're
desperate for right now is international
recognition they're sending emissaries
to china and to russia and to iran and
all over the world to try to get
international recognition so they want
to present themselves as a fully formed
real nation state within the
international order
and one way that they can do that
somewhat persuasively is say we're
really going to crack down on opm and
they're saying we need the help of the
international community for this because
we need investment in afghanistan
because if there's no investment then
they're all just going to make drugs
again
okay they're putting on a good show
then i think probably the most effective
aspect of their press conference
was they were asked about freedom of
speech and they said to the western
world
before you accuse me take a look at
yourself
this question should be asked to those
people who are claiming to be promoters
of freedom of speech
who do
this question should ask to them
there is something
it's in a very dark way but it's still
funny there is something so funny about
hearing
this absolute maniac monster islamist
leader saying like
facebook
and you say hold on wait what was that
word and then you look to the
translation and he's saying don't attack
us over free speech
what what you people in your
civilization do is you let three
unelected billionaire oligarchs led by
hipster rasputin jack dorsey and
zuckerberg and sundar pichai censor
everybody including the duly elected
sitting president he didn't quite put it
in those words but that's the point he's
making
and that's a good point
that's a good point the united states
no longer has credibility the western
world broadly no longer has credibility
to lecture anybody on freedom of speech
because our freedom of speech
has not only been curtailed in practice
right now if i go onto social media and
i say don't mutilate
children's sex organs and pump them full
of cross-sex hormones if i say that
there's a fair chance i will be kicked
off of that platform or temporarily
suspended many people who are listening
to the show right now probably have been
if i go on there and i say i think there
were some problems with the 2020
election i could be suspended if you
question the regime you could you could
be suspended for that if i go on there
and i say you know i'm really wondering
about the efficacy of masks i could be
suspended
at slowing the spread of coronavirus you
know i have some health concerns about
the safety of these vaccines you could
be suspended there are many
many reasons
for which you could be suspended
and kicked out of the public square
because these tech companies control
ninety percent of the flow of
information around the internet
so we have no credibility
to lecture anybody else in the world
on the on freedom of speech because it's
not even just the particular it's not
even just what we're allowed to say what
we're not allowed to say it's who
decides
what we're allowed to say and who we're
not allowed to say what we're not
allowed to say
because it's not even we if it were we
the people setting our own standards as
is the traditional practice in america
setting our own taboos setting the
limits of discourse
fine by me
but it's not it's three radical
billionaires
no credibility whatsoever
no credibility whatsoever
part of the reason that we don't have
the credibility
one to answer these charges
but two even to really occupy the
country any longer in a serious way is
because our country itself is not
unified i was
discussing this topic with a friend of
mine who's you know very
strongly in favor of staying in
afghanistan forever and or nearly very
nearly forever
and he said you know look we stayed in
western europe after the second world
war we stayed there for decades and
decades we stayed in japan we stayed in
korea
not just have bases there but to build
up their countries you say i suppose i
suppose that's true there are some
differences i mean even japan was a real
country afghanistan's never really been
an actual nation but
but even beyond that
america was very different
in the 1940s and 1950s than it is today
america was a much more unified country
america was much more stable country
america was a country that knew what it
believed
america
no longer knows what it believes america
is burning down its own cities
last summer america does not trust the
results of presidential elections not
this one not the last one not many in
recent years
america
because it doesn't have the will to to
be a nation even anymore because america
is pulling down
her own statues her own leaders her own
forebears
america has a harder time
projecting strength over say forget
about being an empire we've got to first
be a nation
can't do that
and you see people on the left silly
people on the left
continuing to egg this on people on the
right i think have had enough of it
but people on the left i think are the
aggressors here
i don't i don't think i'm being hyper
partisan or biased or whatever i mean
the cultural revolution started from the
left that's just an undeniable fact of
history i trace it in my book speechless
it began with the left hollowing out our
institutions the universities the
federal government certainly
hollywood the media all turned against
the country
now big technology adds on to that
upending every standard upending every
belief debunking deconstructing
everything that we cherish even upending
our own language so we don't even speak
the same language anymore so what is it
any is it any wonder that the left in
this country views the right as
just as much their enemy as the taliban
i mean this is what stephen colbert
the leftist comedian alleged comedian on
cbs
late night this is what he said about
concern that we're no different than the
taliban
if you have not heard about our reader's
past it's a great bargain for the
content for just four bucks a month the
daily wire readers pass unlocks
exclusive editorial content that unpacks
trending political and cultural topics
penned by everyone from ben shapiro to
dan crenshaw to me that's right when you
sign up with readers pass you also get
access to the morning wire newsletter or
monday through saturday email covering
the top stories that you need to know
available only to daily wire members all
of this can be yours for just four bucks
a month so act fast because right now
we're offering a one month free trial
get a reader's pass today we'll be right
back with a lot more
the late night host stephen colbert a
left winger
sees no difference between american
conservatives
and the taliban
he's right
we've had troops there for 20 years
they fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack
in america planned in a foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
got our own on capitol hill january 6th
you know the insurrection you know
remember that the worst coup d'etat in
american history because the horn guy
danced around the capital you remember
because the smiley guy took pelosi's
lectern
ridiculous ridiculous
in in
comparison to the actions of the taliban
or al-qaeda of course the january 6th
people
did absolutely nothing
in comparison to american leftists in
2020 the january 6 people did absolutely
nothing
you're right we do have insurrectionists
and terrorists in the country they
burned down they burned down multiple
cities during 2020 including federal
courthouses and police stations and
private businesses and private homes and
they killed a lot of people
and they were all on the left and they
all get a pass
and they're all protected by the regime
is it any wonder we're so divided
this is how they feel though it's
perfectly fine for the left to do that
because the left is part of the regime
and the right can't do that because the
right is out the right is
scapegoated and ostracized
there's a there's an ad that just went
up in
new york city you can see it on some of
the subway stations
it's a doctor
pointing a needle at a person and it's a
person wearing a hat with an upside down
america american flag on it which is
actually has a lot of symbolism to it
we'll get to in a second and he's
screaming and he's saying no and his
hands are up like please stop don't and
it says get the effing vaccine
and then a doctor
forcibly jabbing it into this person
the needle's not quite in him yet but
it's obviously in that direction the
guy's saying no
now
as you'll be well aware
vaccine hesitancy in new york city is
not
mainly a function of right wing white
male trump supporters okay
vaccine hesitancy in new york city is in
large part among black new yorkers
majority black new yorkers not not
vaccinated
and i don't think that they are mostly
trump supporters okay but the image the
idea here is that the trump people are
not only the cause of our national
problem various sort of mundane national
problems and political issues the trump
supporters are murderers they're they're
murderers not just in capitol hill where
they
uh according to
fiction murdered police officers it
didn't happen but the new york times
said that it did
later they had to admit that it didn't
but no one followed up on the correction
they're murdering people through the
disease and they're the cause of it
they're the cause of the germs they're
the cause of the cough they're the cause
of the death blame them
you'll see the hat that they're wearing
it's not a full-on maga hat but it is a
red hat and the american flag is upside
down now what does that mean the
american flag upside down represents a
nation in distress
so
there are two ways to read that one is
that the
awful trump supporters mistakenly
believe that the nation is in distress
but it's not you see the nation is
perfectly fine they just can't get with
the program they're so ridiculous just
take that take the effing vaccine
or
it's a symbol that they are the cause of
the nation's distress that's even even
worse both are shocking but that's even
more shocking they're the problem
america will not be safe and stable and
orderly and just until these guys are
taken care of
so take
the effing
vaccine
there's another one right next to it
wear the effing mask
if
the liberal regime had any credibility
they wouldn't need the edgy posters
they wouldn't need the swear words
this is what happens people like less so
colbert a little bit colbert jon stewart
and john oliver certainly they they
don't make points they don't make
arguments they i mean they're comedians
but even comedians are supposed to make
a point right that's what's funny about
it is they're making an observation and
it has logic and it has reason to it and
they don't do that generally what they
do is they'll just make an observation
they'll just state a fact about the
world and then they'll state it more
loudly and say the f word
they'll say like
you should take the vaccine take the
effing vaccine you know and then it's
like oh okay i guess that he said the f
word and yelled it so i suppose that
how persuasive wow you got me if they
had arguments that were persuasive they
wouldn't need to do that
people people don't need to yell and
scream and use all sort of vulgar
language and threaten you if
they are persuasive but also the regime
doesn't need to be persuasive one it
can't be but two it doesn't need to be
because they've got
all of the power
get the effing vaccine if you don't get
the vaccine what's going to happen to
you well
if you go to quinnipiac university it's
a university in connecticut
and you do not get the vaccine
you will not have access to the internet
you will not i'm serious
the uh quinnipiac university
just sent out an email to students
announcing lots of fines and fees and
some of which are quite expensive
hundreds of dollars thousands of dollars
for not taking the experimental drug
about coronavirus
the email also announced that
unvaccinated students
will lose access to the university's
wi-fi system if they don't meet the
vaccination requirements by september
14. so you basically just can't
you can be there you can continue to pay
them tuition and room and board but
you won't be able to do anything
now you might argue in the case of
quinnipiac you might argue look
whether the school is right or wrong
about the actual medical science and the
public health benefit what they're
trying to do here is protect the safety
of students maybe i don't agree with
their methods or even with their
with their perception of the threat of
coronavirus but
they're trying to protect public health
okay maybe you can say that
maybe you can say that
in new york right now
the majority of black new yorkers are no
longer allowed into museums this policy
officially went into effect two days ago
it will not be enforced until
uh september 13th will not be enforced
citywide but the policy officially went
into effect even though it won't be
enforced what does that mean
government's complicated i guess
especially in new york
but
assuming that the policy is the policy
if you're unvaccinated you can't go into
museums which means
that
well over two-thirds of black new
yorkers cannot go to i think the
vaccination right among black new
yorkers right now is something like 28
so
the majority of 72 percent can't go into
museums anymore
one imagines this will raise some civil
rights questions
something about that seems wrong doesn't
it
but still you might say okay it looks it
looks a little ugly especially on the
racial politics here but
still the new yorkers are just trying to
protect public health okay well i've got
i've got proof for you
that this is not about protecting public
health
the proof is
the las vegas raiders
the raiders
football team
opening up the stadium
and saying if you want to come to the
game you need to take the shot
so what happens if you show up and
you've got your football ticket
you see but you don't have proof of
vaccination
you can either leave or they will give
you the shot
at the stadium
wow okay and then if you get the shot at
the stadium
you can go in but you've got to wear a
mask
do you see the problem here
do you see how they've just admitted
that this is not about public health
when you just receive the shot
you are not actually immunized against
the coronavirus or any other virus when
you receive a shot in the minutes and
hours after you receive that shot you do
not have immunity the way vaccines work
is it takes some time days or weeks
that's what the health officials tell us
happens with coronavirus if you
want to prove that you're vaccinated
it's not enough to get the shot you've
got to then wait several weeks and show
enough time has passed
so
they don't care if people come in
who are not inoculated against the
coronavirus now you do have you have to
wear the mask though
right that's that's the difference if
you're fully vaccinated you don't need
to wear the mask if you're vaccinated
you need to wear the mask or if you're
not fully vaccinated you have to wear
the mask
but
if that's the case then just let people
come in with the mask
why do you need to stick them with the
needle
the effect on immunity is going to be
exactly the same the effect on public
health is going to be exactly the same
by your own admission
because this is not about public health
this is not
about
the immunity or the spread or this or
that or the other thing
we've already been told that the virus
is spreading
somewhat significantly among people who
have the vaccine
though perhaps the symptoms of it are
mitigated
we're already told that vaccinated
people need to wear the masks
it's about the imposition
it's about not just what
these people are deciding these people
without credibility
but it's about who gets to make the
decisions
by the way lots of evidence that the
these coronavirus lockdowns are very bad
for your children's health
study just came out
from the british medical journal
and this this was of personal interest
to me
because i had a child that was born
during the coronavirus lockdowns
british medical journal very respected
medical journal has a peace app says
children born during the coronavirus
lockdowns score 22 points lower
on iq tests
so this is a longitudinal study of 672
kids from rhode island
uh it has run since 2011 so it's
obviously long before the lockdowns and
the pandemic
and it's measuring students uh
average iq score the mullen scales of
early learning and it shows that
children born
during the lockdowns
scored an average iq of 78 that's a drop
of 22 points from the average of
previous cohorts
this study was funded
before i know youtube's going to try to
take me off for this for reading the
study this study was funded by the nih
it was funded by the united states
national institutes of health it is
awaiting peer review peer review is fake
anyway but it's a waiting peer review uh
before it's it's publication in jama
pediatrics but a pre-print copy is
available online it's being pushed out
here by the british medical journal
here's what the study says quote we find
that children born during the pandemic
have significantly reduced verbal motor
and overall cognitive performance
compared to children born pre-pandemic
moreover we find that males and children
in lower socioeconomic families have
been most affected results highlight
that even in the absence of direct
coronavirus infection and covet 19
illness
the environmental changes associated
with the covet-19 pandemic have
significantly and negatively affected
infant and child development so this is
the key here the question is well maybe
it's just the virus that's making these
kids dumber it's not
the researchers ruled that out largely
because mothers or children with a
history of testing positive for covid
were excluded from the analysis
this makes perfect sense by the way
this is pure common sense if you take
kids
who are learning so rapidly right little
kids are just little sponges so they're
learning by seeing people's faces seeing
their expressions going out seeing the
neighborhood seeing different stores and
restaurants in church and just taking in
all of this information if you lock them
inside and then put filthy cloth over
your face and you don't even let them
see your expressions
then
that's going to be a problem
now fortunately i don't think this is
going to be a problem for my cute little
baby boy whose doctor says he's very
advanced he told me that just a couple
days ago i'm sure he never says that to
any other parent
it's not going to be a problem for my
little baby boy because my wife and i
have basically ignored all of the stupid
health
suggestions from the cdc and from the
politicians and from the public health
establishment
i mean i'm not saying we've gone out
licking doorknobs but we've just ignored
what we think are ineffective onerous
imprudent
pointless rules
and i'm
damn well glad that we did because
there's now this study
showing it's a study from a real journal
funded by the nih which just ostensibly
is a real institution that shows that
this is having a really negative effect
on people because there are consequences
of these lockdowns even beyond the
spread or mitigation of the cough
i feel we cannot let a day go by at this
point without playing a clip from libs
of tick tock
my one of my favorite twitter accounts
and i and i do this not merely by the
way
to
make fun of these silly people on tick
tock or wherever
that's part of it too i i won't deny it
but i do it because and i think this is
the reason behind libs of tick tock's
twitter account i do it because
i want to
remind people that the kooky ideas that
float around the academy or the float
around the elite circles of this country
have an actual effect on the ground
among ordinary people who are just
spouting off on social media the crazy
academic theories that began in the
fever dreams of
lunatic psychologists medical doctors
theorists people like paul money people
like wilhelm reich people like the
western marxists who had an effect on
the academy in the 20th century those
ideas among all those super
sophisticated people
with lots of books and fancy live quotes
those have an effect on the culture
pretty directly so this video going
around
tik tok
of this kooky lady she's a preschool
teacher
discussing
how elated she was to see how quickly
her preschoolers
took to radical gender theory and the
perfectly ordinary normal talk
about kids genitals story time
this has been my first year in preschool
with a class of my own teaching
alongside another queer neurodivergent
educator and we have been rocking our
two's class we've been talking about
gender and skin color and consent and
empathy and our bodies and autonomy it's
been fabulous
but our teaching team is shifting and a
new person is being onboarded someone
with many years of experience so today
at the lunch table when the topic of
gender and genitals came up one of our
students plainly looked up and said well
i'm a girl today but i know that teacher
co isn't no they're envy
and the look on the incoming teacher's
face was priceless
she was shocked in a good way and she
just looked around at the two of us and
said this class is incredible and i am
so impressed
[Music]
we need to ban theater kids from ever
participating in society i say this as a
former theater kid so you know i did if
i i
but
we got us i i'm calling for a complete
and total shutdown of theater kids until
we figure out what the hell is going on
because this cannot cannot be allowed to
stand the most depressing part of this
video by the way
is not
that this woman has access to
preschoolers
it's not
that she is talking about genitals at
the lunch table with
preschoolers
it's not even that
it's that the older teacher comes in
and sees this
horrific offense taking place
and is shocked okay so you're like oh
good good finally some
some reason here
shocked in a good way oh
no i give up i give up
i give up get me out of here
this is
the sort of
educational apparatus that is raising
your children and you're sending them
there when i was a kid we didn't go to
preschool i guess some people did i
didn't go to preschool when my father
was a kid people didn't really go to
kindergarten all that much
now it's you know you'd start school at
either six or five i started at five now
it seems you start at four or three some
people i kid you not i have friends and
relatives who send their kids to school
at two
and then you stay in school longer it
used to be if you graduated high school
you were fine for most jobs and now it's
you have to get some associates or maybe
a bachelor's or maybe a mass i mean i
know people who can't write an english
sentence who are getting master's
degrees
which is insane you shouldn't but the
idea is you are now in this educational
apparatus to raise your children to
comport with the the dictates of the
liberal regime
you're there for
forever i mean you're there for now what
20 years sometimes
not good stuff not good stuff maybe we
need to start taking a more active role
in educating people maybe when we
criticize the bizarre kooky theories of
people around the world we ought to we
can do that just fine but we ought to
criticize our own and maybe uh fix those
as well we are being governed by
psychopaths before we go i have to
i have to play this this clip this came
out from the world economic forum this
is an organization basically of just
global elites neoliberal elites who want
who
want to rule the world and in many ways
do rule the world and they're telling us
how wonderful the covet lockdowns are
yeah maybe it made your kid an idiot but
you know it's really going to be
wonderful maybe it shut down your church
and your business and took away a lot of
your money and your rights but hey it's
going to be better for you in the long
run because
we are going to
have even more control take a listen
five ways the pandemic could reshape our
lives in the long term this is the text
popping up one offices will be
reimagined
okay the shift to homework will mean
offices can serve different functions
they could be used as a client showroom
okay a research lab yeah well we already
have those or somewhere to meet with and
reconnect with colleagues well why do we
need to reconnect we used to just be
with them every day
no no you'll just work at home forever
in your pod the advent of 15-minute
spaces neighborhood hubs could replace
some of the perks we miss not by not
commuting to the office
so maybe they'll have gyms or bars or
art galleries or networking
opportunities
yeah we'll just build all these new
things and you would be no more than a
15-minute walk from your home okay wow
that's nice
work more you know the rise of cloud
markets ghost kitchens restaurants that
solely deliver takeaway meals exploded
in popularity during the lockdowns
these could morph into cloud markets
okay
okay analytics driven services that
license and deliver food to you from a
range of brands you don't get to go to
the restaurant but we'll bring slop to
your pod number four you could be
identified by your heartbeat facial
recognition systems are often stumped by
face masks
but your heartbeat is just as unique as
your face
so nasa has developed a system that can
id you from your heartbeat using a laser
number five digital technology will
change the hold on wait a second wait
what was the number four well no yeah
the technology and the learning and
that's and then i know the museums and
the cloud
no after the i want to go to the one
after the cloud market
but before the digital or oh nasa
invented
laser beams that will identify you by
your heartbeat so that even if you mask
you can't hide from the surveillance
state
isn't that great
and this is the one this is the new
normal this is a great reset get used to
it you'll own nothing and you'll be
happy i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles she'll see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
says he has no regrets about the
afghanistan collapse and his botched
strategy and our military leaders say we
have no capacity to rescue americans in
afghanistan that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen